est ce que tu fous là je crois que ça
aille plus loin de prendre l'avion et
que tes faux seins ils détestent ils ont
divorcé il ya 20 portes aux fêtes et
pour tout le monde c'est pour ça qu'on
quitte qui doivent elles au mariage de
leur fille en grèce le volcan islandais
explose
mais en fait l'avion va être détournés
va atterrir munich et ils vont être
obligés de trouver un moyen pour aller à
ce mariage prévu en trois jours d'une
grande force dans la folie du coup
ces genres la guerre
il ya un truc qui me ferait super
plaisir c'est que tu meures daniela est
restée des amis ils sont écrites a
tourné ensemble leur complicité
existantes à n'a pu que se développer
dans le tournage ne vous inquiétez pas
pouvoir utiliser d'autres personnes qui
ne seraient ce très très bien pour jouer
un ancien couple c'est quand même très
intéressante code pour démarrer les
belles voitures de notation ils ont créé
ça pour les voleurs et les demeurés
j'ai tourné avec elle il ya plus de 20
ans ont des petits sujets que je faisais
pour la télé en vidéo son budget après
ça on s'est perdu et on s'est retrouvé
là pour retourner ensemble
on s'était pas vu depuis 20 ans entend
forcément une petite appréhension du
début de comment il travaille exactement
aujourd'hui actions ce qui évidemment ce
dingo en fait pas du tout du tout la
tête tu es tout et entend ça bouge ça
bouscule pas mal donc c'est à dire 3 du
bon bon bon bon bon
et moi qui ai fait moi qui la raison que
ça marche bien comme ça non non rien au
french france en france est attendu pour
sa campagne et tout ça je m'en suis pris
plein la figure
oh non c'est pourquoi la mauvaise
d'aller lever jo de dons mais tu es un
peu galéré qui s'est s'est pas fait en
un clic le filet de l'indication voir
mais sûrement les moyens la toile à ses
trois balles à la tomate et c'est vrai
qu'ils perdent les premières prises
avant je pensais être tout le temps
après
voiture non fumeur